♪ ♪ ♪
- Le coup d'envoi de la saison
estilele est lancé,
dans la région de Niagara.
♪ ♪ ♪
Après deux ans d'accalmie,
les touristes sont finalement
en ville.
Un retour qui permet
à l'industrie de redémarrer.
Mais en pleine campagne
électorale provinciale,
une autre course retient
l'attention...
- Je ne suis pn n n gros
fanatique de Ford, mais je sais
que...
- Thierry Clément est
propriétaire d'un restaurant
à Niagara depuis 2009.
Dans sisisisine, les assiettes
ont recommencé à défiler
et sa salle à manger reprend
vie. Mais les cicatrices
de la pandémie demeurent.
THIERRY CLÉMENT, propriétairedué
- On a perdu notre clientèle.
Dans certains cas, on a même
perdu nos employés. Donc après,
c'est comme si on devait tout
recommencer, mais avec en plus
des dettes, parce que quand
même, on a pris des dettes,
dans ce coup-là.
- Face à l'incertitude de
la relance économique, Thierry
votera pour les conservateurs,
même s'il croit que
le gouvernement Ford n'en a pas
assez fait pour son industrie.
- Ils nous offrent rien
de spécial, c'est vrai, mais
je sais pour moi que si je pars
un peu plus à gauche, je risque
de souffrir beaucoup plus, quoi.
- Au Château des Charmes aussi,
on se prépare à une grosse
saison, avec une cinquantaine
de mariages au calendrier.
PAUL-ANDRÉ BOSC,
PDG du Château des Charmes
- Déjà, on voit qu'on va êtr
très, très, très occupés cet été
s'il n'y a plus de "lockdown",
bien sûr.
- Un été occupé qui n'effacera
pas pour autant les séquelles
de la pandémie.
- Ça, c'est notre business
principale.
- Paul-André Bosch, qui est
aussi exportateur de vin,
pense que le véritable retour
à la normale prendra des années.
- Ce n'est pas juste le tourisme
qui a souffert, c'est aussi
les ventes et les exports
de nos vins.
- Préoccupé par la reprise
économique, Paul-André donnera
son vote au candidat
des conservateurs : l'homme
d'affaires Bob Gail.
- Bob, c'est un ami personnel
depuis, je dirais, 25 ou 30 ans.
- Si le milieu d'affaires penche
pour les conservateurs, Niagara
reste une région néo-démocrate.
En 2018, le NPD y a remporté
trois sièges sur quatre.
Et le comté de Niagara Falls
vote orange depuis huit ans.
Paul Goss votera pour le NPD,
et pense que la plupart
de ses voisins feront de même.
L'historique néo-démocrate
de la région ne semble toutefois
pas déeseseseseses troupes
de Doug Ford. La semaine
dernière, le premier ministre
sortant s'est rendu dans
la région deux fois
en deux jours. Et Doug Fordomomn
de politiciens locaux,
comme le maire Jim Diodati.
La dernière fois, Jim avait
appuyé le candidat libéral,
mais le maire est convaincu
que le vent a tourné
dans sa région. Il croit
que les conservateurs ont
de bonnes chances de l'emporter.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un électorat changeant qui
pourrait pencher d'un côté ou
de l'autre, le jour du scrutin.
Bleu, orange, rouge ou vert,
il faudra attendre le 2 juin
pour le savoir.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Niagara